y
[Música]
hay alerta en europa por el aumento de
casos de la variante de omicron del
virus del hoy 19 que ha sido detectada
en al menos 5 naciones de ese continente
ante el alto riesgo de transmisión
varios países han re implementado
pruebas pcr y prohibido los vuelos desde
varias naciones del sur de áfrica
continúan las protestas y disturbios que
empezaron en contra de la vacunación
obligatoria en los territorios franceses
de ultramar de guadalupe y martinica
pero progresivamente han expuesto el
descontento social el gobierno galo
indicó que está dispuesto a discutir la
posible autonomía de guadalupe
honduras última detalles para las
elecciones generales de mañana el
consejo nacional electoral y las fuerzas
armadas indicaron que la seguridad está
garantizada en todos los centros de
votación pese a los numerosos hechos de
violencia electoral que dejan casi 30
fallecidos
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos esta emisión de
noticias en europa donde república
checa- fue el más reciente país en
confirmar un contagio de la variante
omicron del virus del coi 19 en países
bajos hay casos sospechosos de viajeros
provenientes de sudáfrica donde el nuevo
linaje fue detectado por primera vez la
situación ha llevado a varias naciones a
re imponer pruebas pcr y a prohibir los
vuelos desde varios países del sur de
áfrica donde omicron ya ha sido
confirmada
alerta máxima en el aeropuerto
internacional schiphol de amsterdam este
viernes se hicieron obligatorias las
pruebas de kobe 19 para todos los
pasajeros procedentes de sudáfrica los
viajeros estuvieron atrapados durante
horas en el aeródromo sin riesgo alguno
por la propagación de la variante
omicron recién detectada
y las personas que se han sometido a las
pruebas reciben los resultados por
teléfono y no saben lo que va a pasar
después la gente está cada vez más
alterada quieren comida y hacen saber su
malestar de los 600 pasajeros examinados
61 resultaron positivos para el virus y
tuvieron que entrar en cuarentena por el
momento no es posible determinar si eran
portadores de la variante o micrón
el miedo comienza a crecer en toda
europa ahora con varios casos detectados
en alemania bélgica reino unido e italia
mientras se analizan unos 50 casos
sospechosos la organización mundial de
la salud expresó su preocupación por la
variante que según los expertos podría
ser altamente contagiosa benítez
tenemos que averiguar si hay que
modificar las vacunas todo esto se puede
hacer bastante rápido porque algunas de
ellas son fácilmente modificables pzifer
y modernas han anunciado que tardarían
aproximadamente tres meses modificar sus
vacunas para combatir la nueva variante
omicron desde la ciudad de washington la
vicepresidenta estadounidense de kamala
harris hizo un llamado a recibir las
vacunas y las dosis de refuerzo como
medida de prevención ante la nueva
variante que ha sido calificada de
altamente transmisible
me han informado y como ha dicho el
presidente vamos a tomar todas las
precauciones
por eso hemos tomado las medidas que
tenemos pero nuevamente no puedo
enfatizar lo suficiente uno si no ha
recibido la vacuna de refuerzo a valorar
la importancia de vacunarse para
aquellos que no han sido vacunados lo
que digo siempre lo diré porque es
verdad
son seguras las vacunas son seguras son
gratis y te salvarán la vida continúan
las protestas se disturbios en los
territorios franceses de ultramar de
guadalupe y martinica las
manifestaciones iniciaron en contra de
la vacunación obligatoria para bomberos
y personal de salud pero ahora se
centran en demostrar el descontento
estructural que viven los ciudadanos por
la pobreza y la falta de autonomía en
forma luís muñoz
a una nueva jornada de ira en el
ultramar francés en guadalupe el sábado
se repitieron las manifestaciones
mientras en las noches hombres armados
disparan contra policías y manifestantes
y esto es martinica el sábado amaneció
con una estación de servicio y una
oficina de correos calcinadas la crisis
social no cesa estamos reclamando
nuestros derechos aquí en martinica
esperaba que rompieran que robaran pero
no 15 enviar en una gasolinera te das
cuenta una estación es una bomba pero la
presión ha surtido efecto y la
vacunación obligatoria para personal de
salud y bomberos se ha [__] hasta
el 31 de diciembre
ahora las demandas van mucho más allá
desnudando otras grietas en el pacto
social
el ministro de ultramar sebastián de
cognis anunció el viernes el inicio de
negociaciones para aumentar la autonomía
ciudadanos de guadalupe sienten que la
medida de la vacunación vino impuesta
desde francia nosotros los ciudadanos e
incluso los representantes elegidos no
tenemos la sartén por el mango aquí en
guadalupe en cuanto a la toma de
decisiones el ministro también anunció
la creación de mil puestos de trabajo
subvencionados para jóvenes en guadalupe
una medida que busca recuperar la paz
social en una región de francia donde el
34,5 por ciento de la población vive
bajo el umbral de la pobreza
a continuación otras protestas alrededor
del mundo que son noticia este sábado
cerca de 3000 personas marcharon en
parís contra la extrema derecha y el
racismo en algunos puntos se registraron
altercados entre grupos de manifestantes
y la policía que finalizaron con dos
arrestos uno por porte de material
prohibido y otro para un control de
identidad en madrid la capital española
miles de policías se manifestaron en
contra de una reforma a la ley de
seguridad ciudadana de 2015 que según
aseguran podría obstaculizar su
capacidad para hacer su trabajo la ley
le permite a las autoridades multar a
los medios de comunicación que difundan
imágenes no autorizadas por la policía
lo que quedaría eliminado con la
modificación la policía iraní y dispersó
con gases lacrimógenos una protesta por
la falta de agua en la ciudad de isfahán
los ciudadanos exigen a las autoridades
que abran las compuertas de una represa
para aliviar zonas afectadas por la
sequía del río local que se ha secado
progresivamente a causa de las ffaa a
causa de las fábricas en la zona
en otras noticias honduras celebra
elecciones generales este domingo de las
que saldrá el sucesor del presidente
juan orlando hernández el país se
encuentra envuelto en una ola de
violencia electoral que ha dejado casi
30 asesinados lo que ha despertado la
preocupación de organismos
internacionales para analizar esta
información conectamos con lester
ramírez él es analista y director de
transparencia y gobernanza de la
asociación para una sociedad más justa
bienvenido a france 24 cómo surge esta
violencia electoral quiénes son los
responsables de estos asesinatos y
también de las amenazas a candidatos
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
esta violencia electoral es parte de la
violencia estructural que tiene el país
no es una violencia que se viene
acarreando ya por muchos años y en estos
momentos por la fuerte competencia
electoral no hay una competencia por el
botín estatal por un lado de decir aquí
está en juego prácticamente
y un patrimonio del estado está en juego
para muchas personas también tener un
empleo y poder una subsistencia tanto
para esta persona como para su familia
pero también aquí interviene también
actores oscuros del crimen organizado el
narcotráfico pandillas entonces es parte
de toda esta
estructura que tenemos que cada cuatro
años también se convierte en violencia
electoral no bueno y en medio de este
panorama cuáles son los principales
retos para quien sea el nuevo mandatario
de esa nación
bueno obviamente el principal reto es la
reducción de la pobreza siete de cada 10
hondureños
vive en una situación de extrema pobreza
prácticamente viviendo únicamente con 12
euros al día en la generación de empleo
es otro tema que muy tante y eso está
muy vinculado también con la situación
del gran éxodo migratorio que tiene el
país y por tercer el lugar también tiene
que hacer el combate a la corrupción y
el estado del derecho no la corrupción
en nuestro país honduras mata y quita
oportunidades para acceder a la salud y
oportunidades para la educación y quita
oportunidades para una calidad de vida
digna entonces yo creo que eso se deben
ser los tres problemas prioritarios
además de eso tenemos un gran problema
de energía eléctrica que este gobierno
está generando a un nuevo gobierno
aplicar una deuda de más de seis mil
millones de euros que en la empresa
estatal debe a sus proveedores y
generadores de energía
en los comicios de 2017 en los que el
presidente hernández fue reelegido
fueron tildados de fraude por la
oposición hay garantías de que este
proceso electoral será transparente
bueno en este proceso electoral lo que
tenemos ahora es la representación del
partido de oposición especialmente el
partido libertad y refundación que en el
proceso anterior no estaba ahora está
representado en el órgano electoral está
representado también en las mesas
electorales en este sentido hay
garantías que al menos el voto se va a
cuidar pero siempre hay dudas sobre la
integridad del proceso tenemos un
sistema de transmisión en electrónico de
resultados que todavía hay mucho mucha
incertidumbre de su funcionamiento el
día de mañana y eso sin duda alguna va a
generar suspicacias de fraude va a
generar suspicacias de
inconsistencias que en cualquier momento
si no se abrirán los resultados a tiempo
si la población queda a la espera de los
resultados emprende los preliminares sin
duda alguna va a detonar situaciones de
conflictividad y violencia que van a
abordarse en las calles donde vamos a
tener situaciones fuertes posiblemente
de un mes si no se dan los resultados
septiembre pues señor ramírez a usted
muchas gracias por compartir este
análisis con nosotros en france 24 en
otras noticias en burkina faso cerca 100
personas protestaron por lo que
califican como el fracaso del gobierno
en su lucha contra las facciones de al
qaeda el aumento de la violencia por
parte de los militantes islamistas
acrecienta el descontento en esa nación
africana los manifestantes también piden
que las fuerzas francesas abandonen el
país andrés granadillo nos amplía
en burkina faso el descontento con el
gobierno se sintió en las calles acusan
al presidente rock kaboré de fracasar en
su lucha contra la violencia de
militantes islamistas
desde que él está en el poder los
terroristas están sembrando la
desolación en este país y él es incapaz
de encontrar una solución a este
problema por eso le pedimos su renuncia
inmediata hoy y ahora mientras no
renuncie no iremos a casa
la policía disolvió la protesta con
gases lacrimógenos en respuesta al
movimiento antigubernamental que lleva
varios meses activos las autoridades
cortaron el acceso a internet móvil hace
una semana y se negaron a autorizar la
manifestación de este sábado hace dos
semanas militantes vinculados al qaeda
mataron a 49 policías además de cuatro
civiles en la ciudad de innata al norte
del país
los ataques han alimentado el
descontento contra el gobierno y también
contra las fuerzas militares francesas
que lo apoyan en su lucha personal ma
jian pero personalmente creo que cambiar
de presidente nunca ha resuelto ningún
problema siempre genera otros problemas
mando
de gala lo que pedimos es echar a
francia de áfrica porque cuando vemos
que hay bases militares francesas en
áfrica estos países siempre tienen
problemas
hace cinco años francia lucha en la
región contra militantes de al-qaeda y
el estado islámico pero la inestabilidad
política ha socavado la lucha regional
contra estos grupos terroristas el
presidente prometió cambios en el
gobierno y el ejército para intentar
remediar la crisis mientras los
extremistas ganan terreno en la región
del sahel de áfrica occidental
en rusia un tribunal de siberia ordenó
la detención de cinco personas durante
dos meses por el accidente en una mina
de carbón que mató a 51 personas ellos
están acusados de desobedecer las normas
de seguridad los capturados son el
director de la mina dos gerentes y dos
inspectores de seguridad los dos últimos
se emitieron este mes un certificado
aprobando las operaciones cuando en
realidad no habían hecho ninguna
inspección en el lugar
finalizamos en españa' que encendió sus
luces navideñas para marcar el inicio de
la temporada y en medio de una alta
afluencia en madrid la instalación
cuenta con 11 millones de luces al
tiempo que en barcelona los colores
inundaron sus icónicas fuentes en málaga
miles de personas equipadas con sus
tapabocas y celulares se reunieron en la
calle larios para ser testigos del
espectáculo
con estas imágenes llegamos al final de
esta emisión de noticias quédense con
nosotros que volvemos en breve
[Música]